When we have 2 different ways to refer to the same object,
that's called aliasing.
Aliasing in programs is similar to the way we think about aliasing in Spycraft.
You might not be able to tell from my drawing,
but this is James Bond.
And we can refer to James Bond
either by his name, James Bond,
or by his spy name, 007.
Both of those are ways to refer to the same person.
If something happens that changes the state of James Bond,
so instead of pleasantly enjoying a martini, like he is now,
the bad guys are after him, and he grabs his gun
and is no longer so happy, well, that affects the state
of both James Bond and 007.
Both names refer to the same person,
so whatever state that person has is true for both names.
Aliasing for variable names
has the same property, so if we have 2 variable names
that refer to the same object, any change we make to the object p refers to
also affects the value that q refers to.
If we did an assignment using p to change the value
in the second position on p,
that also changes the value the name q refers to.
If we do an assignment like this where instead of changing the value
of one of the cells that's part of the p object,
we assign p to a new value, well, this assignment
we create a new object, a list containing 3 elements,
the numbers 007.
And it will change what the variable p refers to
to point to that new object.
The value of q is the same as it was before.
It still points to the same object, which we haven't modified.